This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
这是一个iHeart播客。百分之百的人性化。2%。这是在有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人数比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。欢迎收看我的播客《2%》。我将在奇妙的现代世界中，剖析心理韧性、健身以及培养抗挫力的科学。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
经历一些艰难困苦，你会脱胎换骨，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。请收听《2%》。即数字“2”加percent，在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听。欢迎收听“Look Back at it”播客。从1979年开始，那对我和我来说是一个重要时刻。84年对我来说意义重大。
I'm Sam Jay. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
我是萨姆·杰伊。我是亚克斯·英格利西。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。和我们的朋友、喜剧演员同行以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔聊80年代。84年是疯狂的一年。那真是疯狂的一年。我认为没有哪一年对黑人来说比这更重要了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Keer Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen and learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast.
在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听“Look Back at it”。嘿，大家最近怎么样？欢迎收听《用惨痛方式去学习》，我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人基尔·盖恩斯。这个空间专注于黑人男性的经历，进行真诚的对话，这些对话在其他任何地方进行其实并不安全，但你是在和一个懂行的有执照的专业人士交流。多少男人穿着一套盔甲。它向世界传递出一个信号：你是不好惹的。但这并不意味着因为你有这种能力，就必须这样做。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听并学习《用惨痛方式去学习》。
In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Ellen, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian. Michael Mancini.
2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的生父。但这次怀孕似乎是一场骗局。埃伦女士，你两次篡改了这个特定的测试，对吗？我篡改了一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探，才能揭露出一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格，一个女同。迈克尔·曼奇尼。
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the podcast. the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology.
我惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《爱情陷阱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着节季的继续，劳拉·欧文斯最终面临了后果。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《爱情陷阱》播客。大家好，欢迎回到《你二十岁的心理学》，这是一个探讨我们在二十岁时遇到的一些重大生活改变和转折，以及它们对我们的心理意味着什么的播客。
Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we of course break down the psychology of your 20s. this is an episode that I've wanted to do for such a long time and it's just kind of continued to sit on the list waiting for me to like pick it up one day and today is that day because we are going to be talking about female friendships specifically the preconception that they are inherently difficult that they always end up spiraling or codependent or toxic and why that may be or if that is even the case spoiler alert it's a lot more complicated. than that. I also asked you all the listeners to contribute to this episode. I wanted to hear your
大家好。欢迎回到节目。欢迎回到播客。无论你是新听众还是老听众，无论你身处世界的哪个角落。非常高兴你能来到这里，收听新的一期节目，当然，我们要剖析的是你二十岁的心理学。这一期节目我想做很久了，它就一直静静地躺在待办清单上，等着我哪天去开启它，今天就是那个日子，因为我们要谈论的是女性友谊，特别是那种根深蒂固的观念，即女性友谊天生就很艰难，它们总是以陷入混乱、相互依赖或有毒告终，为什么会这样，或者事实果真如此吗？剧透警告，情况要复杂得多。不仅如此。我还邀请了你们所有听众为这一期节目贡献内容。我想听听你们的
stories of female friendship, the good, the bad, the in between, what you've learned, what you wish you'd known sooner. And what I was really surprised by was how absolutely divided we are. There were two very, very distinct boats. Boat One was people who have maybe had some bad experiences in the past, but truly believed that female friendship was one of the greatest gifts, was so meaningful, supportive, intimate, they wouldn't give it up in a second. The second group of people were those of you who really had been burned perhaps a few too many times, who saw female friendships as too dramatic, too over-hyped, too intense. I'm someone who sits right in the middle.
女性友谊故事，好的，坏的，夹在中间的，你们学到了什么，希望自己能早点知道什么。而真正让我感到惊讶的是，我们的观点是多么的绝对分裂。有两种非常、非常截然不同的阵营。第一阵营的人可能过去有过一些糟糕的经历，但他们坚信女性友谊是最伟大的礼物之一，是如此有意义、充满支持和亲密无间，他们绝不会放弃。第二阵营的人则是那些可能受过太多次伤害的人，他们认为女性友谊太戏剧化、被过度吹捧、过于激烈。而我本人就坐在正中间。
I think your friends are your first loves, and that often, means that they will also be some of your first heartbreaks. Humans are inherently very, very flawed, but the nature of female friendships, being that they are so vulnerable, so deeply feeling, so intense, makes them equally special and sometimes disastrous. And I think that they have an increased tendency to fall apart because of the things that make them so beautiful, because they are so intimate and expressive and deep, because we place a lot of expectations on them. But also because of this female rivalry that is very much stoked by a patriarchal society that would have us compete for male attention that would make us constantly compare ourselves. What I want to do in
我认为你的朋友是你的初恋，通常这意味着，她们也将成为你最初的心碎来源。人类天生就是非常、非常充满瑕疵的，但女性友谊的本质，由于它们是如此脆弱、情感如此深厚、如此激烈，使得它们同样特别，有时也充满灾难。我认为它们更容易分崩离析，正是因为那些让它们变得如此美好的特质——因为它们如此亲密、富有表现力、深刻，因为我们对它们寄予了很高的期望。但也因为这种女性之间的竞争，它在很大程度上是被一个 патриархальный（父权制）社会所煽动的，这个社会让我们为了男性注意力而竞争，让我们不断地拿自己作比较。我想在
this episode is explore this and really dive into the complexity of female friendship. I really want to move past all those stereotypes that women can't have longstanding friends because they are just too catty or bitchy or dramatic or mean. And actually, look at the psychology here, that why is it the case that so many of us are having an experience in which our female friendships burn so bright, but also end up burning out quite quickly or exhaust themselves so soon? Beyond that, how do we recover from the tragic female friendship breakup and manage that heightened, magnified bond between us and our girlfriends? How do we make sure that those relationships and those connections last. There is so much to explore today.
这一期节目中做的是，探讨这个现象，真正深入了解女性友谊的复杂性。我真的想抛开那些陈词滥调——即女性无法维持长久的朋友关系，因为她们太爱挑剔、刻薄、戏剧化或卑鄙。而是真正来看看这里的心理学：为什么我们当中有这么多人，都在经历着这样的体验：我们的女性友谊燃烧得如此炽热，却又以极快的速度燃烧殆尽，或者那么快就精疲力竭？除此之外，我们该如何从悲惨的女性友谊破裂中恢复过来，并管理我们与闺蜜之间那种被放大、加剧的纽带？我们如何确保这些关系和连接能够持久？今天有太多内容要探讨了。
I also have to say, once again, a huge thank you to you, the listeners, and to those of you who contributed, thank you for your honesty, thank you for your candor, thank you for how expressive you all were. It is bound to be a very, very illuminating episode, I think, and if you've ever asked yourself, why is this so hard? Why is this so strained when it comes to your female friendships, this is a great place to start. So without further ado, let's get into it. I'll go on the record, straight out the gate and say that I don't think that female friendships are inherently bad or hard or toxic. I don't think that they're doomed to fail. Rather, I think that part of what makes female friendships so tricky and intense is also what allows them to be so
我还要再次对你们——听众们，以及所有贡献了内容的人表示巨大的感谢，感谢你们的诚实，感谢你们的坦率，感谢你们所有人的直言不讳。这注定会是非常、非常具有启发性的一期节目，我想，如果你曾经问过自己：为什么会这么难？为什么在面对女性友谊时总是如此紧张？这是一个很好的起点。那么闲话少说，我们直接进入正题。我先开诚布公地表个态，一开局就直说，我不认为女性友谊天生就是坏的、艰难的或有毒的。我不认为它们注定会失败。相反，我认为女性友谊之所以如此棘手且强烈，部分原因也正是让它们变得如此
beautiful and fulfilling. The good and the bad go hand in hand. Female friendships are so deep and intimate, but that also means that there are higher expectations attached, which can weigh heavily on the relationship. Female friends have so much in common. We have so many of the same emotions, the same feelings towards the world, a lot of the same experiences, but that can also make a hotbed for comparison. We often end up telling our female friends everything. They make us feel so strong, so supported. But when the friendship changes, when something slightly shifts gets in the way, it can be so devastating because we feel the separation even more profoundly. In my experience, the female friendships that work really, really well are those that find that really small,
美好和充实的原因。好与坏是相辅相成的。女性友谊是如此深刻和亲密，但这同时也意味着伴随着更高的期望，这会给关系带来沉重的负担。女性朋友之间有太多的共同点。我们有许多相同的情绪，对世界有相同的感受，有很多相同的经历，但这也可能成为相互比较的温床。我们最终往往会把一切都告诉女性朋友。她们让我们感到如此强大、如此被支持。但当友谊发生变化，当有什么微小的改变挡在中间时，可能会带来毁灭性的打击，因为我们感受到的分离感更加深刻。以我的经验，那些真正、真正运作良好的女性友谊，是那些找到了非常、非常
tiny slice of balance. Each person expects the same from the other person, is giving the same, feels the same about their friend, they are mutually secure or have done or have done the work to kind of address their insecurity. And they also tend to have the same conflict style. So it's not skewed. One person, you know, doesn't enjoy confrontation whilst the other person is conflict diverse. That's something that we don't often think of. But I hear, here so many examples of people with friends who suddenly up and left or suddenly confronted them with all these problems that have been building up for ages. And I think that a lot of what that comes down to is having a skewed idea of conflict
微小平衡点的友谊。每个人对另一个人有相同的期望，付出相同的努力，对朋友有相同的感受，她们彼此相互安全，或者已经完成了、正在努力解决各自的不安全感。而且她们往往有着相同的冲突风格。所以它不是倾斜的。一个人，你知道的，不喜欢对抗，而另一个人则回避冲突。这是我们通常不会想到的事情。但我听到、听到了太多这样的例子：人们的朋友突然一走了之，或者突然把积压了很久的各种问题劈头盖脸地向她们发泄出来。我认为这在很大程度上归结于对冲突抱有歪曲的看法，
and a skewed idea of how to address problems. If you want long-lasting friends, sometimes you do actually have to be able to have it out and argue and work through it, but it's about coming to that from the same kind of perspective. And as women, we are so conditioned into being conflict-averse, to not coming off as dramatic. We don't want to fulfill that bitchy stereotype. And that often has the opposite effect of making us more emotionally cut off. We have such intense, close connections that eventually every emotion becomes magnified. But the problem is that we have only ever learned how to cope with the fluffy good feelings.
以及对如何解决问题有歪曲的看法。如果你想要持久的朋友，有时你确实必须能够敞开说出来、争吵并解决它，但关键是要以同一种视角来对待这一点。作为女性，我们受到的规训是回避冲突，不要显得太戏剧化。我们不想符合那种刻薄的刻板印象。而这往往会产生相反的效果，让我们在情感上更加封闭。我们有着如此强烈、紧密的联系，以至于最终每一种情绪都被放大了。但问题在于，我们只学会了如何应对那些轻快美好的情绪。
So the friendship is really, really intense. But so is the times when someone disappoints you or someone hurts you. But we don't know how to have those difficult conversations. It's something that I think men have an advantage in when it comes to friendship. They are typically allowed to be more confrontational because people expect them to be less in control of their emotions. and they've also normally been conditioned to be more outwardly expressive for specific feelings, not for, you know, feelings like sadness or talking about what's making them depressed or unhappy. No, those things we know are very much a suppressed emotion for men.
所以友谊确实非常、非常激烈。但当有人让你失望或伤害你时，这种激烈程度也是一样的。然而我们却不知道如何进行那些艰难的对话。我认为这是男性在友谊方面占优势的一个地方。他们通常被允许表现得更具对抗性，因为人们预期他们对情绪的控制力较弱，而且他们通常也被训练成对特定感觉有更多外在表现，而不是针对，你知道的，比如悲伤的情绪，或者谈论是什么让他们感到沮丧或不开心。不，对于男性来说，这些东西我们都知道是被极力压抑的情绪。
But when it comes to things like anger, frustration, stress, those are permitted to have an outward expression. So, of course, that often gives them sometimes an excuse to be violent. but on a deeper level when men are angry at a friend, they tend to just say it or show it. Women are a lot more subtle. Some people might say that women play mind games. I think it's a little bit more complicated than that. I think that we just don't want to jeopardize the friendship by just speaking out our fears and speaking out our problems, but that actually ends up having the reverse effect of making the friendship harder.
但当谈到愤怒、沮丧、压力这些事情时，它们是被允许有外在表现的。所以，当然，这通常往往会给他们提供一个使用暴力的借口。但在更深层次上，当男性对朋友生气时，他们往往会直接说出来或表现出来。女性则要委婉得多。有些人可能会说女性在玩心理游戏。我认为这要稍微复杂一些。我认为我们只是不想通过说出恐惧和问题来危及友谊，但这实际上最终会产生相反的效果，让友谊变得更加艰难。
And I was speaking to my boyfriend about this, just kind of getting his opinion on his friendships with other men and how they resolved conflict. Firstly, he said that they didn't have any conflict, which I was like, okay, well, congratulations. But when I pushed him a little bit further, he was like, well, we'll just have a fight. And he said this, and I don't know, take what you want from this, but he said, I'd much rather get like a punch in the face and have it be over and done with and know how they felt, then slowly be iced out over the course of three months and lose that friendship entirely.
我和我的男友谈过这件事，只是想听听他对与男性朋友的友谊以及他们如何解决冲突的看法。首先，他说他们没有任何冲突，对此我的反应是，好吧，那恭喜你们了。但当我进一步追问时，他说，嗯，我们就是打一架呗。他这么说，我不知道，你们从中学到什么就拿什么吧，但他原话说：“我宁愿挨上一拳，然后事情就此了结，知道对方是怎么想的，也总好过在三个月的时间里慢慢被冷落、最后彻底失去这段友谊。”
And studies have shown that men and women do fight differently. For men, and especially between the same gender within the same sex. So men fighting men, women, finding women, it's very different. I feel like everyone has some idea of that. But for men, in whatever form it is, it's often more direct and practical. Some would say violent. For women, it can also be violent, but it can be emotionally violent. and it's often more indirect and once again emotional,
研究表明，男女的争吵方式确实不同。对于男性而言，尤其是同性别之间——也就是说男性和男性争吵，女性和女性争吵，这是非常不同的。我觉得每个人对此都有所了解。但对男性来说，无论以何种形式，通常都更直接、更务实。有些人甚至会说是暴力。对于女性来说，这也可以是暴力的，但它可以是情感上的暴力。而且它通常更间接，同样也是情绪化的，
which leaves a lot more room for interpretation and hurt feelings without resolution. So that's my first big point. Maybe female friendships are, you know, harder because we actually don't know how to fight with each other. We don't know how to communicate the hard things. And we don't want to come off as if we're being too bitchy or demanding or emotional, or by addressing our feelings. But we also, I think, have this aversion to talking about the hard things about our relationship with someone because we think that we won't be able to recover from that.
这留下了更多解释的空间，也留下了没有得到解决的情感伤害。所以这是我的第一个大观点。也许女性友谊之所以，你知道的，更艰难，是因为我们实际上并不知道如何彼此争吵。我们不知道如何沟通那些艰难的事情。而且我们不想因为直面自己的感受，而显得自己太刻薄、太苛求或太情绪化。但我认为，我们对于和某人谈论我们关系中艰难的事情也有一种天然的排斥，因为我们觉得我们无法从中恢复过来。
We're so used to being supportive, being there for them in their conflicts with other people. We don't want to experience that ourselves. Of all the stories you submitted, one of the biggest themes was also friendships that just ended because someone ghosted the other person. That was such a huge theme. Sometimes even after five to ten years of friendship. Here was one of the stories shared by a listener. My best friend of 13 years just stopped talking to me.
我们太习惯于提供支持，在她们与其他人的冲突中陪伴她们。我们自己并不想经历那种情况。在你们提交的所有故事中，最大的主题之一就是有些友谊仅仅因为一方“人间蒸发（ghosting）”另一方而告终。这是一个巨大的主题。有时甚至在维持了五年到十年的友谊之后也是如此。以下是一位听众分享的故事。我相交13年的闺蜜突然不理我了。
She said I had done something, refused to say what, refused to meet for weeks, refused to speak to me. Then, when I couldn't do the one date she suggested, she kicked off and said that I was being unfair and dramatic. It's such a weird thing because I really don't know what went wrong. The last time I had seen her, she'd come to a party I'd hosted for Galentine's Day. She shut herself in a room, had taken the gifts, barely spoke, and then when I mentioned a photo of the group ran from the room.
她说我做了某件事，但拒绝透露是什么事，拒绝见面几个星期，拒绝跟我说话。然后，当我无法赶上她提议的那个约会日期时，她大发雷霆，说我不讲理、太戏剧化。这真是一件奇怪的事情，因为我真的不知道哪里出了问题。我最后一次见到她时，她来参加了我举办的闺蜜节（Galentine's Day）派对。她把自己关在房间里，拿了礼物，几乎没说话，然后当我提到一张集体照时，她从房间里跑了出去。
It has been strange. I was the one to comfort her after that experience. I was the one to try and fix it. In the end, after some advice for my friends, I realized I was a 24-year-old in a teenage argument and told her I wasn't going to continue the friendship. that just complete shutdown from her end must have been so difficult to manage. And here's the thing, I'm sure she has her side of the story as we all do. But what I find equally interesting and strange about female friendships is that, again, we talk about nearly everything else in our lives,
这真的很奇怪。在那次经历之后，是我去安慰她的。是我试图修复这一切。最后，在听取了朋友的一些建议后，我意识到我是一个24岁的人却在进行一场青少年式的争吵，于是我告诉她我不会再继续这段友谊了。她那种彻底关闭沟通的做法一定很难应对。问题是，我相信她也有她那一版本的说法，正如我们所有人都有一样。但我在女性友谊中发现同样有趣且奇怪的是，再次强调，我们几乎会谈论生活中的所有其他事情，
but we really struggle with talking about our feelings towards a person to that person, especially when they are deemed to be negative. the easiest solution therefore is to just avoid them all together and to cut them off you know openly communicating with your friends is hard at first but i think it's something that you realize as you mature you get what you give from that from that argument from that conflict from just putting it all on the line right often having it out saying what you're feeling really addressing the core problems or rot in your relationship provides you with a better relationship your friendship improves because it's part of your journey we're going to move on from that now because I feel like we've spent enough time talking about
但我们真的很难向某人开口谈论我们对这个人的真实感受，尤其是当这些感受被认为是负面的时候。因此，最简单的解决方案就是彻底避开她们，和她们断绝关系。你知道，与朋友进行公开沟通一开始很难，但我认为这是你随着成熟会意识到的一点：你从那场争吵、那场冲突中付出多少，就能收获多少，只要你把一切都摊开来说，通常情况下，敞开心扉、说出你的感受、真正解决你关系中的核心问题或溃烂之处，会带给你一段更好的关系，你的友谊会因为这是你成长之旅的一部分而得到改善。我们现在要跳过这个话题了，因为我觉得我们花在探讨冲突上的时间已经够多了，
conflict but this does kind of link me to a separate point about why we find female friendships so hard but also so rewarding they are just more expressive they are more complex and therefore more intense. A big element of this is the level of disclosure that we have in female friendships, which is basically a fancy way of saying we tend to tell each other everything. There is nothing that is off limits, too private, to TMI, we're constantly chatting about every little detail in a way that men typically don't. I had one male listener write in and say, I always felt jealous of female friendships and wish I had that same bond with my male friends because from the outside female friendship seems so involved and deep.
但这实际上与我的另一个独立观点有关，即为什么我们觉得女性友谊既艰难又充满回报：它们只是更具表现力，更复杂，因此也更加激烈。其中的一个大要素是女性友谊中的披露程度（level of disclosure），这基本上是一种高级说法，意思是我们的倾向是把一切都告诉对方。没有什么事情是禁区，没有什么隐私是不能说的，没有什么信息是过量的（TMI），我们不断地在聊每一个小细节，这是男性通常不会做的方式。我曾有一位男性听众写信说，我总是嫉妒女性友谊，希望自己和男性朋友也有那种纽带，因为从外表上看，女性友谊似乎非常投入且深厚。
I feel like none of my male friends want to hear about how my day went, what I ate for lunch, what I'm feeling, my heartbreak. Telling each other everything might seem kind of unimportant and obvious, but that level of disclosure builds familiarity quick. It builds trust rapidly, both of which are core foundations of interpersonal attraction, and bonding. The same kind of bonding that happens sometimes between siblings or family members or between you and a romantic partner, the more you share, the more memories you have, the more you let people into your private, hidden internal life, the deeper the connection becomes. And we get to that
我觉得我的男性朋友没有一个想听我倾诉我今天过得怎么样、午饭吃了什么、有什么感受，或者我有多心碎。把一切都告诉对方可能看起来有些微不足道、显而易见，但这种披露程度能够迅速建立熟悉感。它能迅速建立信任，而这两者都是人际吸引和建立纽带的核心基础。就像有时在兄弟姐妹、家庭成员之间，或者在你与浪漫伴侣之间发生的同一种纽带一样，你分享得越多，你们的共同记忆就越多，你让人们走进你的私人、隐藏的内心生活就越多，连接就会变得越深。而且我们能达到那种
level of vulnerability faster because we tend to be more open sooner into the friendship. Why exactly do we do this. So there is this textbook titled The Evolutionary Psychology of Women that is fantastic. I never thought that I would be recommending a textbook, but here I am. And I love this. I don't know why. I just find this book really, really fascinating. And they have this whole chapter on female friendship titled, More Like a Sister, Women in Friendship. And in it, the author speaks about how female friendships are firstly more intense and exclusive than those of men because of how much we communicate. We already knew that, but this causes the friendships that women develop to really mimic the close communal relationships normally found between blood relatives, which is why we feel
脆弱程度的速度更快，因为我们在友谊初期往往更早地敞开心扉。这究竟是为什么呢？有一本名为《女性进化心理学》的教科书，非常棒。我从未想过自己会推荐一本教科书，但事实就是如此。我很喜欢它。我不知道为什么。我只是觉得这本书真的、真的非常吸引人。它们有一整章专门讲女性友谊，题为“更像姐妹：女性与友谊”。在其中，作者谈到女性友谊首先比男性的友谊更强烈、更排他，原因在于我们沟通的频率。我们已经知道了这一点，但这导致女性发展出的友谊真正模仿了通常在血亲之间发现的紧密公共关系，这就是为什么我们会觉得
like sisters. We feel like there is, we're more than friends, we're more than friends. There is this strong focus on empathy and a responsiveness to other people's needs. Maybe in the past from an evolutionary perspective, this helped support child care needs where women needed that trust through chatter in order to rely on each other more. Or it would have helped with survival when the men were away to ensure that the women were bonded within the family group, even when they weren't related, to still feel like they were related. And what does this actually produce? What does this constant chatter communication bring with it? Well, mainly it's intimacy and its vulnerability. You feel like you know someone so well and they know you. As one of you put it, my female friends are the only
像姐妹。我们觉得有某种东西，我们不仅仅是朋友，不仅仅是朋友。这里有一个对同理心的强烈关注，以及对他人需求的响应。也许在过去，从进化的角度来看，这有助于支持育儿需求，女性需要通过闲聊建立这种信任，以便更多地依赖彼此。或者当男性不在家时，这有助于生存，以确保女性在家庭群体内部紧密相连，即使她们没有血缘关系，也依然感觉像有血缘关系一样。这实际上产生了什么呢？这种源源不断的闲聊沟通带来了什么？好吧，主要是亲密感和脆弱感。你觉得自己非常了解某个人，而对方也了解你。正如你们其中一位所说，我的女性友谊是唯一能
people who see me for who I am as a person. My parents see me as their daughter, my siblings as their little sister and my boyfriend as his girlfriend. And all of those are select versions of me. But my girlfriends see me exactly how I come. They don't care if I'm obedient or sexy or smart or loyal, they like me just for me. And there is a real platonic love there. Letting someone be their authentic self is an act of true love. So firstly, we have a vulnerability that emerges. And from that vulnerability comes the second component, which is expectation. If I've opened myself up and you have as well, if you know me deeper than anyone has ever known me, I begin to expect something more from you. You know, when I need help with something, when I'm going through a hard time, a breakup, you'll be there for me.
让我作为一个真实的人被看见的地方。我的父母把我当成他们的女儿，我的兄弟姐妹把我当成他们的妹妹，而我的男友把我当成他的女友。所有这些都是我身上的特定版本。但我的闺蜜们看到的完完全全就是真实的我。她们不在乎我是不是听话、性感、聪明或忠诚，她们喜欢我就只是因为我是我。这里有一种真正的柏拉图式的爱。让一个人做真实的自己，是一种真正的爱的表现。所以首先，我们展现出了脆弱性。而从这种脆弱性中诞生了第二个成分，那就是期望。如果我已经向你敞开了心扉，而你也是如此，如果你对我了解得比任何人都深，我开始对你抱有更多的期待。你知道的，当我需要某方面的帮助，当我经历困难时期、经历分手时，你会陪在我身边。
That's what we begin to believe. We have this mutual acknowledgement that if we trust each other, if we're vulnerable with each other, and therefore we love each other, we'll show that through effort and favors and time. but at what point do those expectations get out of hand? And what happens when you slip up? You know, you're going through a hard time, you're misreading signals, you can't show up for your friends the way that they have for you in the past,
这就是我们开始相信的。我们有一种共同的认知：如果我们彼此信任，彼此坦诚，因而我们彼此相爱，我们就会通过付出努力、帮对方忙和投入时间来表现这一点。但这些期望在什么时候会失控呢？当你搞砸了会发生什么？你知道的，你正在经历困难时期，你误读了信号，你无法像过去那样为朋友挺身而出，
then things kind of explode. The reason that female friendships are so hard is because there is a huge expectation to, yes, almost be like sisters or family to one another. And sometimes that's really hard to do for everyone around you. It's really hard to do for everyone around you. It's really hard to do for every single one of your friends. You get kind of tired and it kind of feels like eventually you need to take a step back.
然后事情就会有点爆发。女性友谊之所以如此艰难，是因为存在着巨大的期望，要求彼此几乎像姐妹或家人一样相处。有时这对你身边的人来说真的很难做到。这对你身边的每一个人来说真的很难做到。要对你的每一个朋友都做到这一点真的太难了。你会感到有些疲惫，而且感觉最终你需要退后一步。
You need to see other friends. You need to be your own person or you're going to let them down. Here's a story about that from a listener. When I was in my 20s, I found it really hard to maintain close female friendships and have girlfriends because I would expect too much of them. I had a friend who we will call Sally, who I got really close to in my first year out of high school. We would do everything together. I'd never really had a best friend before,
你需要见见其他朋友。你需要做回你自己，否则你会让她们失望。下面是一位听众关于这方面的一个故事。在我20岁的时候，我发现很难维持亲密的女性友谊和拥有闺蜜，因为我对她们的期望太高了。我有一个朋友，我们叫她萨莉，我们在高中毕业后的第一年变得非常亲密。我们做什么都在一起。我以前从未真正有过闺蜜，
and she made me feel so happy, safe, seeing all of those things. But then I started to notice her putting some distance between us. I would expect her to answer instantly and she no longer was. Or I would do favours for her and she wouldn't reciprocate. She also started to make better friends. The expectations we have are sometimes too high because our female friendships can mean so much but you can't rely entirely on one person because sometimes that would smother them.
她让我感到非常快乐、安全，看到这一切。但我开始注意到她开始和我们保持一些距离。我期望她能秒回消息，而她不再这样做了。或者我为她付出了，而她没有回报。她也开始交到更好的朋友。我们所抱有的期望有时太高了，因为我们的女性友谊可能意义重大，但你不能完全依赖某一个人，因为有时那会让人喘不过气来。
So I've learned to lower my expectations. This made me quite sad to hear because it's a question I think a lot of us have when it comes to friendship. Do you give up that heightened level of intensity and intimacy? Do you lower your expectations just a little bit for the sake of longevity, even if you don't get as much out of the friendship? Or do you bet everything on this friendship? Do you get the matching tattoos? Do you become insanely close?
所以我学会了降低期望。听到这个让我挺难过的，因为这是我认为我们在面对友谊时都会有的一个问题。为了长久，你是否要放弃那种高度的激烈和亲密？哪怕你从友谊中获得的没那么多，你也愿意稍微降低一点期望吗？或者你把一切都押在这段友谊上？去纹情侣纹身吗？变得疯狂亲密吗？
Knowing that this could eventually change and you could lose this bond. It's complex. There is no one answer. Yet again, that's the dilemma when it comes to these almost codependent situations. They burn bright, but they can burn quick and eventually you need to settle down. That's going to be an adjustment period. And during that period is when things can become tricky, managing expectations. Now, something we need to talk about that we haven't yet is jealousy.
明知这一切最终可能会改变，你可能会失去这种纽带。这很复杂。没有唯一的答案。再说一次，这就是陷入这种相互依赖的困境时的两难选择。它们燃烧炽热，但也可能迅速熄灭，最终你需要安定下来。那将会是一个适应期。而正是在这个时期，事情可能会变得棘手，也就是如何管理期望。现在，我们要谈论一件我们还没谈过的事，那就是嫉妒。
Jealousy envy competition, because that is possibly one of the biggest contributors to female friendship breakdown I think I have ever encountered. And you are all on my side with this. So many of you noted that women are constantly pitted against each other in almost every circumstance by a patriarchal society that benefits from insecurity. it benefits from women focusing on seeing each other as the problem rather than a system that means we feel like we can't all succeed. Think about it in an online context.
嫉妒、羡慕、竞争，因为这可能是我所遇到过的导致女性友谊破裂的最大元凶之一。你们所有人都站在我这边。你们中有许多人指出，在一个从不安全感中获益的父权社会中，女性在几乎所有情况下都被不断地放在对立面上。它从女性将彼此视为问题所在、而不是去看到那个让我们觉得无法共同成功的系统这一现象中获益。想想网上的情况。
What are women not judged on in comparison to other women? Trolls, online critics, people in the comments will always pit women against each other based on their bodies, their success, their relationship, their careers, and it's hard not to buy into that, especially, especially when male attention gets involved. So we're going to talk about all of that and more after this short break. Stay with us.
有什么是女性不被拿来与其他女性进行比较的吗？网络喷子、网络评论家、评论区的人总是会根据女性的身材、成功、恋爱关系、职业来让她们互相敌对，要不去接受这种叙事真的很难，尤其是，尤其是当男性注意力卷入其中时。所以，在这段简短的广告之后，我们将讨论所有这些以及更多内容。请继续收听。
2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers. researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical
2%。这就是在有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人数比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析心理韧性、健身以及在奇妙的现代世界中培养抗挫力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等进行对话，以看透那些主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的曾认为种子油天然具有炎症性。我们搞错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题，其实都是压力的结果。经历一些艰难困苦，你会脱胎换骨，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。请收听《2%》。即数字“2”加percent，在iHeart Radio应用程序、
and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the IHeart Radio app,
Apple Podcasts，或你获取播客的任何地方收听。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯在VMA颁奖典礼上双击（double-tap）小金（Lil' Kim）的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不关心黑人时？我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小金到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在“Look Back at it”播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·J。我是亚克斯·英格利西。
Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English.
每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。包括最近一期邀请马克·拉蒙特·希尔的节目，大谈80年代的快克可卡因。澄清一下，84年对我很重要，不仅仅是因为快克。我随时准备在白天谈论快克，但只是为了让大家知道。我的意思是，马克，这已经是我们讨论快克的第二集了，所以我开始看出这里有一条隐秘的脉络。
Each episode, we pick you here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack, so I'm starting to see that there's a through line.
我们现在也把艾滋病摆在桌面上，所以。然后你把那句话说完。是的。我认为没有哪一年对黑人来说比这更重要了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的年份之一。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听“Look Back at it”。欢迎收听我的新播客《用惨痛方式去学习》，我是你们的主持人、你们最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯。为了响应心理健康意识月，我将把我在心理健康领域十多年的经验以及与许多不可思议的嘉宾的对话带给大家。
We also have AIDS on the table right now, so. Then you're finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests.
我指的是特里普·方丹，瑞安·克拉克。有时，当我们追求某样东西时，我们太过于沉迷于追逐的过程，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了这样东西。而我们还在继续追逐。我们不知道什么时候才算足够。因为人们在盯着记分牌看。生活变成了关于赢和输。史蒂夫·伯恩斯，达斯廷·罗斯，因为你觉得在世期间做一个好人很重要。
I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, We get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth.
你是一个好人，是因为你害怕吗？因为那是两种不同的动机，兄弟。绝对是的。那是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你纯粹就是为了做一个好人。加入我，基尔·盖恩斯，我们将在我的新播客《用惨痛方式去学习》中，就治愈、成长、父爱、压力和目标展开真实的对话。打开你免费的iHeartRadio应用程序。搜索“Learn the Hard Way”并立即收听。
Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Keir Gaines, is we have. have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now.
2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己处于亲子鉴定丑闻的风口浪尖。随后的家事法庭听证会揭露了她故事中前后矛盾的明显漏洞。这拉开了长达数年的法律战的序幕，旨在证明真相。埃伦女士，你两次篡改了这个特定的测试，对吗？我篡改了一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来破案。我希望人们能看到他们的税款都用在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们将揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格，一个女同，迈克尔·马兰蒂尼。我惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《爱情陷阱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着节季的继续，劳拉·欧文斯最终面临了后果。
In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in someone's correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Grega lesbian, Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences.
女士们先生们，马里科帕县传来突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被指控犯有欺诈罪。在亚利桑那州实现正义之前，这一切都不会结束。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《爱情陷阱》播客。社会有一种奇怪的执念，喜欢让成功的女性互相争斗。为了什么理由？真的，为了什么理由？为了娱乐？
Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped Podcast on the Iheart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Society has such a weird obsession with pitting successful women against each other. For what reason? Truly for what reason? For entertainment?
为了煽动不安全感，为了激怒（rage bait）大众。为了获得点赞、获得浏览量、获得关注。我真的不知道，但这确实影响了我们彼此建立联系的能力，因为很难不去接受这样一种叙事：我们当中只有少数人能成功，只有少数人能成为最好的，而且我们不是在与男性竞争，我们是在与彼此竞争。根据社会持续描绘和看待女性的方式，我们既是彼此最好的朋友和知己，同时也是敌人和头号竞争对手。女性之间确实存在一种历史上的竞争关系，这源于历史上由于歧视和不平等导致女性缺乏机会。直到过去70到60年，女性才真正
To fuel insecurity, to rage bait people. get likes to get views, attention. I truly don't know, but it really does impact how we are able to relate to each other because it's difficult not to buy into this narrative that only a few of us can succeed, only a few of us can be the best, and it's not that we're competing with men, we're competing with each other. We are both each other's best friend and confidant, but also enemy, and number one competition based on how society continues to paint and view women. There is a a real history of female rivalry that comes from a historical lack of opportunities for women due to discrimination and inequality. It's only in the last 70 to 60 years that women really
开始被允许进入领导角色、进入备受尊崇的职业、进入成功和权力的位置，甚至进入某些大学。你知道，像哈佛、牛津、斯坦福这样的大学，很多直到20世纪20年代甚至40、50年代才开始招收男女同校，即便在那时，班级也是分开的，只有大约15%的毕业生是女性。当社会的一部分人——占世界人口50%却只被给予另一群体可用资源的极小一部分的那部分人群——其机会池较小时，这自然会滋生竞争。它滋生的竞争不是发生在两个群体之间，而是发生在资源较少的群体内部——在女性之间，
began to be allowed into leadership roles, into highly esteemed jobs, into positions of success and power, even into some universities. You know, universities like Harvard, Oxford, Stanford, a lot of them didn't even go co-ed until the 1920s or even the 1940s, 1950s, and even then classes were separated and only about 15% of graduates were female. When there is a smaller pool of opportunities for a section of society and for a section of the population that makes up 50% of the world but has only given a small sliver of what is available for the other group, naturally that breeds competition. and it breeds competition not between the two groups, but between the group that has less between women,
在被剥夺了平等的群体之间。这种稀缺心态至今仍在困扰着女性友谊，尽管这种不平等我认为已经开始减少。如果你知道你们群体中的所有男性都能得到实习机会，但女性只有两个名额，而你的10个朋友都在竞争，她们当然是你的朋友，而且你知道有一种同志情谊，尤其是在男性主导的空间里，但也很难不把她们也看作是某种敌人，因为她们可能会得到你真正想要的机会，这会以一种有时男性不必应对的方式影响你们的关系。这就是稀缺背后的心理学，或者说桌上只有一个座位时的情况。
between the group that is deprived of equality. That scarcity mindset still really haunts female friendships today, despite that inequality, I think, starting to diminish. If you know that all the men in your group will get an internship, but there are only two spots for women and 10 of your friends are competing, they're of course your friends but and you know there is that sense of camaraderie especially in a male dominated space but it's hard not to also see them as a bit of an enemy because they might get the opportunity that you really wanted and it can impact your relationship in a way that sometimes men don't have to deal with that is the psychology behind scarcity or there only being one seat at the table
当某样东西很稀有时，我们会赋予它很高的价值，这也意味着所有想要它的人之间会有更大的竞争。这种竞争现在可能没那么夸张了，但对于我们的母亲和祖母那一代人来说，它是非常突出的。而这些人正是我们学习很多社交技能和与他人交往方式的对象。说实话，这对我来说很有趣
when something is rare we place a lot of value on it, which also means greater rivalry between the people that all want it. That competition may be less exaggerated now, but for our mothers and our grandmother's generation, it was very prominent. And those are the people who we learn a lot of our social skills and way of relating to others from. It's interesting really to me
，听到我妈妈和我朋友的妈妈对她们的女性朋友有着与我们现在如此不同的态度。我总是能想到的一个例子是，我的一位闺蜜不久前买了一条跟我一模一样的裙子。那是那种非常可爱的黑色海滩裙。她为此给我发了短信，还发来了一条非常紧张的语音消息。那条消息足足有五分钟长，她说：“真的很对不起，我买了跟你一样的裙子。我要去退掉它。如果你恨我的话也没关系。”
to hear how my mom and my friend's mother have such different attitudes around their female friends than we do now. An example of this I always think of is one of my best friends a while ago bought the same dress as me. And it's this really cute black beach dress. And she texted me about it and she sent me this really nervous voice message. And it was like five minutes long of her being like, I'm so sorry, I bought the same dress as you. I'm going to return it. You can hate me if you want.
老实说，这真的很奇怪。我说：“不，不，我很喜欢这个。这条裙子美极了。如果是打折买的，你绝对应该留着。我很喜欢跟朋友穿情侣装。谁不喜欢和别人穿同一套衣服出现呢？”在我回了消息大约10分钟后，她给我打来电话说：“天哪，真的很对不起……”
And it was honestly so strange. I was like, no, no, I love this. Like, the dress is gorgeous. If it was on sale, you should definitely keep it. I love being matching with my friends. Who doesn't love showing up in the same outfit as someone? And she called me like 10 minutes later after I messaged her back and she was like, dude, I'm so sorry.
老实说，这真的很奇怪。当时我想，不，不，我喜欢这样。就像，这条裙子太美了。如果它在打折，你绝对应该留着。我喜欢和朋友穿得一样。谁不喜欢和别人穿同一套衣服呢？大约十分钟后，自我回复她的信息后，她给我打来电话，说，伙计，非常抱歉。
That was all my mom. My mom was getting in my head. She was traveling with her at the time. She was making such a big deal about this. She kept saying that, you know, I was going to be mad, that she was a bad friend for copying me. that is a mindset that yes, I think is slowly becoming extinct, but is still present in the generations of the women before us
这全都是我妈的功劳。我妈一直在灌输我这种想法。她当时正和她一起旅行。她把这事儿当成天大的事。她一直说，你知道的，我会生气的，说她是个模仿我的烂朋友。这种心态，是的，我认为正在慢慢消亡，但在我们上一辈女性的世代中依然存在，
in a subconscious way. Like I don't always think that it is them trying to tear each other down, but I do think unconsciously back then, there was more of a sense of competition between their fellow woman, especially women who were in quite a successful group. women know it's harder to get ahead. So we develop more jealousy, envy, we compare more frequently, and that can wear down the relationship. Let's hear from a listener about this because literally I read her DM and I was like this is
是以一种潜意识的方式。比如我不认为她们总是在刻意贬低彼此，但我确实认为，在过去，无意识中，女性同胞之间存在着更强烈的竞争意识，尤其是那些身处相当成功群体中的女性。女性深知出人头地更加艰难。因此我们更容易产生嫉妒、艳羡，更频繁地进行攀比，而这会消磨彼此的关系。让我们来听听一位听众对此的看法，因为我看了她的私信后，真的觉得这就是
spot on exactly what we're talking about. I had a friend whose life fell apart simply because I was doing better than her. We ended up going to the same uni so it felt like we were starting off on the same foot. Very quickly, I began achieving a lot of amazing things in college and my personal. life and it led to the deterioration of our friendship because she confessed she couldn't handle me having more than her and being quote unquote better than her. She even ended up starting therapy because of it. We fell out and haven't been the same since. I truly feel like I'm grieving this friendship because she meant the world to me and I really value platonic friendships as someone
我们正在讨论的痛点。我有一个朋友，她的生活分崩离析，仅仅因为我过得比她好。我们最后上了同一所大学，所以感觉我们站在同一起跑线上。很快，我在大学和个人生活中取得了许多惊人的成就，这导致了我们友谊的恶化，因为她坦白说，她无法接受我拥有的比她多，并认为我比她“优越”。甚至为此开始去看心理医生。我们闹翻了，之后就再也回不到从前了。我真的觉得我正在为这段友谊感到悲伤，因为她对曾经的我来说意味着全世界，作为一个单身人士，我真的很珍视柏拉图式的友谊。
who is single. Anyway, she's moved on with new friends who are in a similar place in life than her and seems very, very content. That's so unfair, because often the first people we want to tell about our successes, our accomplishments, our big wins, is our closest friends. It almost feels less important if our big moments and milestones can't be shared,
不管怎样，她已经开始新生活了，和那些处境与她相似的新朋友在一起，看起来非常非常满足。这太不公平了，因为通常我们最想分享成功、成就和重大胜利的第一批人，就是我们最亲密的朋友。如果我们的重要时刻和里程碑无法分享，它似乎就变得不那么重要了，
especially considering the bond we spoke so highly about, and when you are a single woman, right? It's like you don't have that person that you're in a relationship with to immediately tell everything to, that role is taken on by your friendships. Some people are inherently more insecure about their worth regardless of gender. So do I think that women are just naturally poised to undermine each other
尤其是考虑到我们曾高度赞誉的那种纽带，当你是一个单身女性时，对吧？这就好像你没有一个可以事无巨细立刻倾诉的恋爱对象，这个角色是由你的友谊来承担的。有些人无论性别如何，对自己的价值本身就更缺乏安全感。所以，难道我认为女性天生就会互相使绊子，
and that's what makes our friendship so hard? No, I don't. I think that we actually need to start talking about the impact of male attention as part of this equation as well. Men hold a lot of power. And yes, I mean power in a business, success, career sense, but also in a sexual sense. Those two things can, you know, also come together as well in some of the worst ways.
而这正是我们维系友谊如此艰难的原因吗？不，我不这么认为。我认为我们实际上需要开始讨论男性关注的影响，这也是其中一部分。男性掌握着巨大的权力。是的，我指的是商业、成功、职业意义上的权力，但也是性吸引力意义上的权力。你知道，这两者有时也会以最糟糕的方式结合在一起。
But what is known is that when men like us, that can help us get ahead. And we are socialized to desire patriarchal validation. If a man thinks you're funny or good looking or interesting, you feel like you're in the group. And once you're in that in group, you feel protected. Maybe that in group is in the workplace where once the guys think, you're one of them. You get included in more networking opportunities. You seem more chill and easygoing. You're one of the boys. You're less likely to be picked on or told that you're too
但众所周知，当男人喜欢我们时，这能帮我们平步青云。我们从小就被灌输要渴望父权制的认可。如果一个男人觉得你有趣、好看或有吸引力，你就会觉得自己加入了这个圈子。一旦你加入了这个圈子，你就会觉得自己受到了保护。也许这个圈子在职场上，一旦男人们觉得你是他们的一员。你就会获得更多的人脉机会。你看上去更酷、更好相处。你是哥们儿中的一员。你更不容易被刁难，也不会被告知你太
difficult. It also happens when it comes to romance. You know, finding a partner or a boyfriend can make us feel more secure in our future and protect us from the stigma of being single as a woman in her 30s, as a woman in her 40s who society really requires to be coupled and married and to be a other. That naturally pits us against each other for male attention and approval. And that approval feels more special than female validation because of how the power is dispersed. It's why in a 2019 study, these authors suggested that women stereotypically gossip more about other women as a way of decreasing the value and standing of a female rival who is competing for that desired male attention. It's where slut shaming by other women also comes in, putting another woman down by suggesting that she's less pure, less loyal, less honest, less whatever, not as good as us because she sleeps around.
难对付。在浪漫关系中也会发生这种情况。你知道，找到一个伴侣或男朋友会让我们对未来更有安全感，并保护我们免受作为30多岁、40多岁的单身女性的污名化，社会原本就要求女性必须成双成对、结婚生子。这自然让我们为了男人的关注和认可而互相敌对。而且由于权力分配的方式，这种认可比来自女性的肯定感觉更特殊。这就是为什么在2019年的一项研究中，这些作者指出，女性往往更多地八卦其他女性，以此来贬低和降低争夺所需男性关注的女竞争对手的价值和地位。这也是其他女性进行荡妇羞辱的原因，通过暗示另一个女性不那么纯洁、不够忠诚、不够诚实、不管怎样，因为她到处跟人睡觉，所以不如我们好。
But maybe also feeling jealous of the fact that her being a so-called slut means that men must like her. You can kind of see how complex this gets. I hope that you kind of see where I'm coming from. But at the end of the day, this vying for male acceptance and recognition, makes female friendships hard because we are once again competing for something that will give us power, reassurance, safety, opportunity, maybe even love that we feel like we can't all get at the same time. This actually has a name, especially when it comes to women who are attracted to men. It's called female introssexual competition.
但或许也对这样一个事实感到嫉妒：她成为所谓的荡妇意味着男人们一定喜欢她。你可以看出这有多么复杂。我希望你能明白我的意图。但归根结底，这种对男性接受和认可的争夺，让女性之间的友谊变得艰难，因为我们再次为了能给我们带来权力、安心、安全感、机会、甚至可能是爱的某种东西而竞争，而我们觉得无法同时拥有所有这些。这实际上有一个名字，特别是对于那些被男性吸引的女性而言。它被称为女性同性间性竞争。
And I would really, really recommend looking this up. Let's hear from a listener about this. I hate to admit that a boy came between me and my best friend because it feels so cliche like women only care about men over their friends, but it's what happened. I started a new job and this really nice guy, charming, sweet, attractive was working with me. And through drinking late nights at the office, we became friends. I confided in my best friend who I'd known for five years that I really wanted more and I thought that we had a future together.
我真的非常非常建议大家去查查这个概念。让我们听听一位听众关于这方面的看法。我很不愿意承认一个男孩破坏了我和我最好朋友的关系，因为这听起来太陈词滥调了，就像女性只在乎男人胜过在乎朋友一样，但事情确实如此。我换了一份新工作，一个非常友善、迷人、温柔、有吸引力的帅哥和我一起工作。通过在办公室深夜喝酒，我们成了朋友。我向我认识了五年的最好朋友倾诉，说我真的很想有进一步的发展，我觉得我们俩有未来。
and she told me to invite him to my house party to hang out outside the office. Long story short, he came and I was so nervous, but pretty quickly she spent the rest of the night flirting with him. By the end of the night, they were making out in the corner. The trust between us was ruined at that moment and I was devastated. Flash forward two years later, they are dating and I haven't spoken to either of them in over a year. I really miss our friendship and wish that we haven't lost it over some silly. boy. You know, that example
她告诉我在我的家庭派对上邀请他，以便在办公室外聚聚。长话短说，他来了，我当时紧张得要命，但很快她就把剩下的一晚都用来和他调情。到了深夜，他们已经在角落里热吻了。我们之间的信任在那一刻被摧毁了，我心碎不已。快进到两年后，他们正在约会，而我已经有一年多没有和他们任何人说话了。我真的很想念我们的友谊，也希望我们没有因为一个愚蠢的男孩而失去它。你知道，那个例子
and that story is so rough, but I think is also kind of the perfect example of what I mean when I say that vying for male attention creates competition and that competition erodes the trust that is so
和那个故事太残酷了，但我也认为这完美体现了我的意思——当我\$说追求男人的关注会产生竞争，而这种竞争会侵蚀女性友谊中那种
innate and beautiful in female friendship. The emotional environment created by all that, the intensity, the comparison, the competition, it becomes so heightened that it can be hard not to slip into quite an unhealthy cycle in our female friendships of sometimes needing distance, then feeling guilty for needing distance, pulling them even closer, feeling overwhelmed or
生来就有的、美丽的信任时。由这一切所营造的情感环境——那种强烈感、比较、竞争——变得如此高度紧张，以至于我们有时很难不陷入女性友谊中一种不健康的循环：有时需要保持距离，然后因为需要距离而感到内疚，又把对方拉得更近，感到心力交瘁或
confused, which ends up having the same end, you know, we end up seeing a fizzle or seeing a friendship breakup. Now, this deserves special attention, female friendship breakups. These kind of situations have undoubtedly hurt me more than some romantic breakups. Because you kind of expect men to let you down. And I'm really sorry to any men listening, but that was my experience with a lot of my exes. I was never totally surprised when it ended up going wrong. Every romantic relationship has a potential expiration date. You always, you know, at the back of your mind, at times think, you know, what happens if we break up?
困惑，最终导致相同的结局，你知道，我们最终看到友谊逐渐消逝或分道扬镳。现在，这值得给予特别关注——女性友谊的破裂。毫无疑问，这种类型的情况对我的伤害甚至超过了一些恋爱关系的破裂。因为你多少会预料到男人会让你失望。对于所有正在收听的男性，我深表歉意，但这就是我与许多前任相处的经历。当最终走向破裂时，我从未感到完全意外。每一段浪漫关系都有潜在的保质期。你有时总会在潜意识里想，你知道的，如果我们分手了会怎么样？
I don't think we have that same pessimistic attitude towards friendship, or at least I didn't, or I don't. it feels much more long-lasting. So when it comes to an end, it can be devastating because it's unexpected. You never predicted it. You never prepared for it. I'm going to give you guys a bit of my own story now. I've been relying too heavily on your contributions. But I had this best friend when I was in university.
我认为我们对友谊并没有那种悲观的态度，或者至少我曾经没有，现在也没有。友谊感觉要持久得多。所以当它走向终点时，它可能是毁灭性的，因为它是出乎意料的。你从未预测过。你从未为此做过准备。现在我要和大家分享我自己的故事了。我之前太依赖你们的投稿了。但我在大学时有一个最好的朋友。
We lived together for all four years. She was like the, I think she was the only person to speak at my 21st. We were so close. And then one day she, quite literally moved cities and never spoke to me again or really anyone from that time in our lives just packed up and left and it was devastating and three years on i still have dreams about her i still think about her you know at least once a week funnily enough we now live in the same city and actually in the same suburb so i see her quite a bit and i saw her about a month ago and had this
我们整整四年住在一起。她就像是……我想她是我21岁生日聚会上唯一发言的人。我们曾是那么亲密。然后有一天，她字面意义上搬到了别的城市，再也没有跟我说过话，也没有和我们那段生活中的任何人说过话，就这样收拾行李离开了，这太令人心碎了。三年过去了，我依然会梦见她，我依然（至少一周一次）会想起她。说来有趣，我们现在住在同一个城市，甚至在同一个街区，所以我经常能见到她。大约一个月前我见到她时，
moment where I just kind of watched her from afar with her boyfriend and felt that same really deep sting in my chest all over again. You know, like you were going to be my kid's godmother. For a while, you know, this person knew more about me than anyone. She was the person I went to cry to who I think I loved more than anyone else. I don't think any of my exes really knew me that way. And you just really miss them. You really miss the potential of who this person was going to be. Of course, we know from the psychology around breakups because this is a breakup that what we're feeling is a unique kind of pain or a social pain. The grief associated with losing a valued social connection like a best friend is processed in the same area of our brain that processes when you bang your toe or when you accidentally cut your finger while cooking. Specifically, that pain, the social pain and the real pain is processed by the somatosensory cortex.
那一刻我只是远远地看着她和她的男朋友，胸口再次感到了那种极其深切的刺痛。你知道的，那种感觉就像：你本来要当我的孩子的教母的。有一段时间，这个世界上没有任何人比这个人更了解我。她是我去哭诉时找的人，我想我爱她胜过爱其他任何人。我觉得我的任何前任都不曾那样真正了解我。你只是真的很想念他们。你真的很想念这个人原本可能会成为的样子。当然，我们从关于分手的心理学中得知——因为这是一次分手——我们所感受到的是一种独特的痛苦或社会性痛苦。失去像挚友这样珍贵的社会联系所带来的悲伤，与你在烹饪时撞到脚趾或不小心切到手指时，大脑处理痛感的区域是同一个。具体来说，这种痛苦——社会性痛苦和真实的痛苦——是由躯体感觉皮层
or the dorsal posterior insular. What that basically means is that this loss, this emotional social loss, often has a very tangible sensory component that we feel. Friendship breakups also threaten and really harm core parts of our social identity. As in, you know, I know who I am because you are my friend. I am your friend, you are mine, you love me, I'm a good friend to you, I feel seen by you. A lot of our identity sometimes does come from those relationships with other people and who we are in relation to them. But when that connection is abruptly interrupted or severed, it can leave us feeling
或背后岛叶后部处理的。这基本上意味着，这种失去，这种情感上的社会性失去，通常具有我们可以感受到的非常具体且切实的感觉成分。友谊的破裂还会威胁并真正伤害我们社会认同的核心部分。比如，你知道的，我知道我是谁，因为你是我的朋友。我是你的朋友，你是我的，你爱我，我对你来说是个好朋友，我感到被你看见。我们的很大一部分认同感有时确实来自于与他人的那些关系，以及我们在与他们的关系中是谁。但当这种联系被突然中断或切断时，会让我们感到
really lost and confused and rethinking not just our values or our sense of self, but also like, did I deserve this? Am I actually a bad person? Who do I share things with? Who else knows me this way? it's very isolating on all on all fronts and it's very devastating to say the least so how do we prevent this obviously i think not all friendships are meant to last their time has come sometimes you've outgrown each other and it's a natural separation but despite you know maybe some of the negativity around female friendships that we have highlighted today they are deeply deeply important and intimate and vulnerable and they do sometimes take the place of family or of partners. It's like the quote that your best friend, you know,
真的很迷失、很困惑，不仅重新审视我们的价值感或自我意识，还会想：我配得上这一切吗？我其实是个坏人吗？我和谁分享心事？还有谁像这样了解我？从各方面来看，这都非常孤立无援，而且可以说极其令人心碎。那么我们该如何防止这种情况发生呢？显然，我认为并非所有友谊都能天长地久，它们的期限到了，有时你们彼此成长到了不同的阶段，这是一种自然的离别。但尽管今天我们强调了女性友谊中可能存在的一些负面影响，它们依然极其极其重要、亲密且充满脆弱感，有时它们确实取代了家庭或伴侣的角色。就像那句名言所说：你最好的朋友，
will always be at your wedding, but your boyfriend or your girlfriend might not be. Like, they're meant to outlast a whole lot of other relationships that we have. I think it's just nice to have someone who has seen you at every stage, at every age, and, you know, that you've been lucky enough to develop in parallel with. So let's talk about some tips for maintaining those things. female friendships, even when things get a little bit difficult. So tip number one, communicate just as
永远都会出席你的婚礼，但你的男朋友或女朋友可能不一定会。友谊注定要比我们拥有的很多其他关系更长久。我觉得身边能有这样一个人挺好的：她见证了你的每一个阶段、每一个年龄，而且你们很幸运能并行成长。那么，让我们来谈谈维系女性友谊的一些小贴士，即使在事情变得有点棘手的时候。所以小贴士一：沟通要像对待其他任何事情一样，
much about your frustrations as you do about anything else. I have the saying that someone is only a true and long lasting friend when you've survived your first argument, your first fight, your first bicker, because I believe that that is a huge sign. If you can get through that, if you have spoken about it, that you love and respect each other enough to do the uncomfortable thing for both of you. And for the sake of the relationship. If you feel like your friend is distant, if you're feeling like they're jealous, they're prioritizing other people over you, maybe it's become one-sided. Say something, it feels awkward. And sometimes I do think we shy away from that because we think that it will end the relationship. But at that point, if you are harboring all these really deeply seated
同样多地去沟通你的挫败感。我有这样一句名言：只有当你经历并挺过了第一次争吵、第一次争执、第一次小拌嘴之后，对方才算是一个真正持久的朋友，因为我相信这是一个巨大的信号。如果你能度过那一关，如果你曾开诚布公地谈过，那就说明你们彼此相爱且足够尊重，愿意为了你们双方去做那件让人感到不舒服的事，为了这段关系也是如此。如果你觉得你的朋友很疏离，如果你觉得她们在嫉妒、把其他人看得比你重要，或者友谊变得单方面了。说出来吧，这会让人觉得尴尬。有时我们确实会对此退避三舍，因为我们认为这会终结这段关系。但在那个时候，如果你把所有这些深埋心底的
fears, anxieties, frustrations, the relationship is doomed anyway because you're going to be overwhelmed by the resentment and bitterness that will build up. So you kind of have one of two options. Let the relationship die in silence or kind of fight for it. It doesn't even need to be a fight. Just a moment of honesty where you apologize, you open up, you accept responsibility, you admit, you cry, whatever it is you need to do. I think that that is a really important mark of a good friendship is if you're able to do those things together. Secondly, just because they're doing a similar thing as you, whether that's at school, in the workplace, in your careers in general, it doesn't mean that they're competition. Actually, they can be your inspiration instead, a sign that you can
恐惧、焦虑、挫败感都藏着掖着，这段关系无论如何也注定要完蛋，因为你会被积聚起来的怨恨和痛苦压垮。所以你基本上只有两个选择。要么让这段关系在沉默中消亡，要么为它争取一下。甚至都不需要是一场争吵。只需一个坦诚的时刻：你道歉、你敞开心扉、你承担责任、你承认错误、你哭泣，无论你需要做什么。我认为一个好朋友的重要标志就是你们能够一起完成这些事情。其次，仅仅因为她们在做和你类似的事情——无论是在学校、职场，还是在职业生涯中——并不意味着她们是竞争对手。事实上，她们反而可以成为你的灵感来源，这说明你也能
and are doing it too and that you can, you know, go to each other for advice, go to each other for feedback. When you find yourself comparing, remember that everyone can win and that success is always going to look different on different people. And also, there is no point getting everything you want if you don't have true people to share it with. And that includes these friends. I get the inclination to sometimes see them as competition, especially because of how hardwired our brains are by patriarchy, by so many other things. But please fight against that urge. Speak their praises when they're not around. Be outwards and loud about your admiration for them. And I think that that outwardness and that loudness and that that vibrant approval of like yes my best friend is the
而且正在这样做，并且你们可以，你知道的，互相征求意见，互相提供反馈。当你发现自己陷入攀比时，请记住每个人都可以赢，而且成功对不同的人来说总会有不同的面貌。此外，如果你没有真正的人去分享它，得到你想要的一切也就毫无意义。这其中也包括这些朋友。我理解有时把她们视为竞争对手的倾向，特别是考虑到我们的思维被父权制和许多其他事物深度规训。但请抗拒这种冲动。当她们不在场时，大肆称赞她们。要公开且大声地表达你对她们的钦佩。我认为这种公开、大声且充满活力的肯定——比如“没错，我的最好朋友就是
shit she is cool even if we are in the same industry even if we are doing the same thing like we are we do this together not against each other being very like i said loud about that kind of scares away the insecurity and it scares away the people who want to come to you and implant that competition in your friendship thirdly let the friendship change I saw this amazing perspective around the difference between friendship and romantic relationships. Relationships have these defined stages of commitment. You know, you move in together. You get engaged, you get married, you might have kids.
最棒的，她太酷了”，即使我们在同一个行业，即使我们在做同一件事，我们是一起面对，而不是互相对抗——正如我所说，这种大声的表达会吓退不安全感，也会吓退那些想要接近你并在你们的友谊中植入这种竞争意识的人。第三，顺应友谊的改变。我看到过一个关于友谊与浪漫关系区别的精彩观点。恋爱关系有这些明确的承诺阶段。你知道的，你们同居了、订婚了、结婚了、可能还有了孩子。
Friendships, on the other hand, don't have those same obvious milestones. Because of this, there is more room for transience, inconsistency. You can also have more than one friend in your life in a way that, you know, it's not typical, to have more than one partner. So it's kind of like our romantic relationships have this growth trajectory and our friendships don't have the same kind of path. And so you have to take a step back sometimes and just let them change and develop as they naturally would. Don't get too panicked by the times when one of you is more distant or busy. Let the friendship fade for a little bit when someone moves or someone is traveling.
相比之下，友谊并没有那些同样明显的里程碑。正因为如此，友谊有更多变、不稳定的空间。你的人生中也可以拥有不止一个朋友，而在通常情况下，你不会拥有不止一个伴侣。所以这有点像我们的恋爱关系有一条成长轨迹，而友谊却没有这样的固定路径。因此，你有时必须退后一步，顺其自然，让友谊随着自然规律发生改变和发展。不要对你们其中一方有时变得冷淡或忙碌感到过分恐慌。当某人搬家或去旅行时，让友谊稍微淡化一段时间。
I just think that you need to let the person you love your female friend, your friend of any gender. Let them, you know, change alongside you. And let yourself shift your expectations for the chapter that you're in rather than where you feel you need to be. Really base your friendship on the season and what's going on around you. And I think that that allows it to have a more healthy, healthier life, I guess. I guess it allows it to survive. You know, with every long friendship, there are years and times that you're closer and periods where there is a bit more distance, so you just have to lean in. Finally, this might sound strange, but do more than just talk. Do activities
我只是觉得，你需要让你所爱的人——你的女性朋友，或者任何性别的朋，友——伴随着你一起改变。调整你对当前人生阶段的期望，而不是纠结于你觉得自己应该处于什么位置。真正把你的友谊建立在当下的季节和周围发生的事情之上。我想这会让友谊拥有更健康的生活，我想是的。我想这能让友谊长存。你知道，每一段长久的友谊中，都有彼此更亲密的岁月和时光，也有稍微保持距离的时期，所以你只需要顺其自然。最后，这听起来可能很奇怪，但除了聊天，还要多做一些活动。
as well. I feel like men are always doing things with each other. They always have like activity-based hangouts, like they're doing sport or video games or whatever. And we can learn from that. Talking about our feelings. Catching up is great, but so is making memories beyond our emotions. It's not me saying, you know, be less feeling. Don't talk about that. But I think that we also need to have something else to base our friendship on rather than just talking about what's going on. I was on a girl's trip with one of my best friends recently and we hadn't seen each other in over a year. We booked an Airbnb so it was just the two of us and we spent three days walking around this beautiful neighborhood coming back to our space, cooking meals together, going out.
我觉得男人之间总是一起做事情。他们总是有基于活动的聚会，比如做运动、打电子游戏之类。我们可以从中学习。谈论我们的感受、叙旧固然很好，但创造超越情绪的共同回忆同样重要。这并不是说要让你少一点感性，或者不要谈论这些。但我认为，除了谈论近况之外，我们的友谊还需要有别的东西作为基础。我最近和我的一个好朋友去了一趟闺蜜旅行，我们已经一年多没见了。我们订了一间民宿，只有我们两个人，我们花了三天时间在这片美丽的街区散步，回到我们的空间，一起做饭，出门闲逛。
And it just felt special being able to actively live my life with her rather than just talk about it. And it's something that I want to bring to the friends that I see in my everyday rather than just once a year. I want to finish on a positive note with one more listener story that I think sums everything up perfectly for me. And is such a testament to how beautiful and beautiful and meaningful and important female friendships are, despite their downsides. So let's hear from this final listener. I can count my genuine female friends on one hand. I don't need a whole lot of friends.
能够积极地和她一起生活，而不仅仅是谈论生活，这种感觉真的很特别。这也是我想带到我日常见面的朋友中去的体验，而不仅仅是一年一次。我想以一个积极的音符结束今天的节目，分享最后一位听众的故事，我认为这个故事完美地总结了我所说的一切，并且证明了女性友谊尽管有其负面影响，但它是多么美丽、有意义且重要。让我们来听听这位最后的听众怎么说。我可以用一只手数出我真正的女性朋友。我不需要太多朋友。
At the age of 34 and with some life experience under your belt, you realize that quality always trumps quantity. My girlfriends now are women who I know I can trust and rely on for anything and vice versa. there is never any pressure, never any drama. If there is something bugging us about one another, we are open enough to give and receive feedback in a respectful and constructive manner, not to tear each other down. No longer do I have time for people who leave me feeling anxious, drained, annoyed or pessimistic.
在34岁这个年龄，有了一定的人生阅历之后，你会意识到质量永远胜过数量。我现在的好朋友都是我知道可以信任并赖以应对一切的女性，反之亦然。从来没有任何压力，没有任何抓马。如果我们之间对彼此有什么烦恼，我们都足够坦诚，能够以尊重和建设性的方式给出和接受反馈，而不是为了贬低彼此。我不再有时间去应付那些让我感到焦虑、精疲力竭、烦恼或悲观的人。
Not everyone is for you, and you won't be everyone's cup of tea either, and that's okay. How perfect is that? And I just loved that it came from someone who was no longer in their 20. who's kind of like out of the woods, out of the chaos of this decade, because we have a lot to learn from that example. We have so much to learn from the fact that maybe the order we get, the more the drama, kind of doesn't fit our lives anymore, the meanness, the indirectness. It just doesn't have a place and you've got to really find your people who you can openly
不是每个人都适合你，你也不会是每个人的茶，这没关系。这有多完美？我特别喜欢这个观点，因为它来自于一个已经不再处于20多岁、已经走出了迷茫、走出了那个十年混乱期的人，因为我们能从这个例子中学到很多。我们从中学到了很多：可能我们越长大，抓马就越不再适合我们的生活，那些刻薄和小动作也就失去了容身之处，你真的必须找到那些能够敞开心扉
communicate with, you can have hard conversations with, who make life easier and lighter rather than harder. So thank you so much for listening to this episode. I hope that you learned something about your female friendships, about why they might be difficult, sometimes for all the best reasons, not for the bad reasons, not for the hard reasons. It's just because they are so vulnerable and expressive,
沟通、能够进行艰难对话、让生活变得轻松而不是艰难的人。非常感谢大家收听本期节目。希望你从中学到了一些关于女性友谊的知识，了解到为什么她们有时会变得艰难，有时是出于种种最好的原因，而不是出于糟糕的原因，也不是因为困难的原因。那只是因为她们太脆弱、太具有表现力了，
and sometimes that just makes everything else more intense as well. If there is someone who you think would enjoy this episode, maybe your female bestie, maybe one of your girlfriends, feel free to share it with them, a link. It helps the show grow, helps us reach new people. Make sure that you are following along for future episodes and that you leave a five-star review if you feel cool to do so on Apple Podcasts, Spotify, wherever you're listening. And big thank you for making it this far if you did. I really appreciate you sticking around and I appreciate you listening to this episode and hopefully
有时这也会让其他一切变得更加强烈。如果你身边有谁会喜欢这期节目，比如你的闺蜜、你的女性朋友，请随时把链接分享给她们。这有助于节目的成长，帮我们触达新听众。请确保关注我们的后续节目，如果你愿意的话，请在苹果播客、Spotify或任何你收听节目的平台上留下五星好评。如果你听到了最后，非常感谢你。我很感激你的陪伴，感谢你收听这期节目，希望你
enjoying it. As always, until next time, stay safe, stay kind and please be gentle with yourself. We will talk soon. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO%. on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
喜欢它。一如既往，直到下次再见，注意安全，保持善良，对自己温柔一点。我们很快再聊。2%。这就是有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我们将剖析精神坚韧、健身以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立复原力的科学。经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。即 TWO%可在 IHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听。
On The Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s.
在《Look Back at It》播客中。从1979年开始，这对我和我来说是一个重大的时刻。84年对我来说意义重大。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利ッシュ。每一集中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的。和我们的朋友、同行的喜剧演员以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论80年代。
84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor it?
84年是疯狂的一年。那真是疯狂的一年。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的一年了。在 IHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at It》。嘿，大家好，你们好吗？你们正在收听由你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖姆斯主持的《Learn the Hardway》。这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都真的不安全进行的坦诚对话，但你是和一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士在交流。有多少男人穿着西装或盔甲？
It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen and learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Ellen's, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern.
这向世界发出了信号：你不是好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这么做。在 IHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Learn the Hardway》。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的生父。但这次怀孕似乎是个骗局。埃伦斯女士，你伪造了这份特定的测试两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。
Two more men who'd been through. the same thing. Greg, a lesbian, Michael Ranjini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police.
另外两个经历过的男人。格雷格，一个同性恋者，迈克尔·兰吉尼。我的脑子炸裂了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。
As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯最终面临了后果。在 IHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。这是一档 IHeart 播客。保证由真人制作。本集暂无评论。点击转写中的任意句子即可发表评论。